A pesar de que estos trastornos son muy comunes,
los tratamientos actuales, cuando funcionan,
solamente suprimen los síntomas.
En 1978, cuando Edward Jenner descubrió la primera vacuna,
que fue contra la viruela,
no creó tan solo un profiláctico para la enfermedad,
sino toda una nueva mentalidad:
la medicina es capaz de prevenir enfermedades.
Sin embargo, por más de 200 años,
se creyó que las enfermedades psiquiátricas no eran prevenibles.
Hasta 2014, cuando mi colega y yo descubrimos por accidente
los primeros fármacos que podrían prevenir la depresión y el TEPT.
Los descubrimos experimentando con ratones
y actualmente investigamos si funcionan en seres humanos.
Estos psicofármacos preventivos no son antidepresivos,
sino una nueva clase de fármaco.
Lo que hacen es aumentar la resiliencia al estrés,
así que llamémoslos "potenciadores de la resiliencia".
Recuerden una situación estresante de la que pudieron recuperarse,
quizá una separación, un examen, haber perdido un vuelo...
La resiliencia al estrés es el proceso biológico activo
que nos permite recuperarnos tras el estrés.
Es como cuando el sistema inmune se deshace de un resfrío.
Y una resiliencia insuficiente
en el momento de afrontar una situación de estrés grave,
puede ocasionar un trastorno psiquiátrico como la depresión.
La mayoría de los casos de trastorno depresivo se desencadenan por el estrés.
Y hemos observado que en los ratones
los potenciadores de la resiliencia son capaces de proteger
de agentes estresantes biológicos, como las hormonas del estrés,
y también los factores de estrés psicológicos y sociales,
como el acoso y el aislamiento.
Esto es lo que sucedió cuando dimos a los ratones
hormonas del estrés durante tres semanas.
Es decir, un estresante biológico sin injerencia psicológica.
Esto causa un comportamiento depresivo.
Y si los sometemos a un tratamiento con antidepresivos tres semanas antes,
no se observan efectos positivos.
Pero darles una única dosis del potenciador de resiliencia
una semana antes,
previene el comportamiento depresivo por completo,
incluso tras tres semanas de estrés.
Esta es la primera vez que una droga
consigue prevenir los efectos negativos del estrés.
La depresión y el TEPT
son enfermedades crónicas que, por lo general, duran toda la vida.
Además, aumentan el riesgo de abuso de sustancias, indigencia,
enfermedades cardíacas, Alzheimer, suicidio...
El costo global de la depresión
supera los tres billones de dólares anuales.
Ahora bien, imaginen que pudiésemos predecir qué personas
están en riesgo de experimentar estrés en exceso,
como una voluntaria de la Cruz Roja que viaja a una zona de terremotos.
Además de la vacuna contra la fiebre tifoidea,
podríamos darle una pastilla o inyección del potenciador de resiliencia
antes de su viaje.
Así, cuando sea presa de criminales o algo peor,
al menos estará protegida contra el riesgo de desarrollar depresión y TEPT
después del incidente.
No evitará que el accidente le ocasione estrés,
pero le permitirá recuperarse de ello.
Y eso es lo revolucionario del fármaco.
Al aumentar la resiliencia,
podemos reducir drásticamente
su susceptibilidad a la depresión y al TEPT,
y quizá evitar así que pierda su empleo, su casa, su familia o incluso su vida.
Luego de que Jenner creara la vacuna contra la viruela,
aparecieron muchas otras vacunas con gran rapidez.
Pero pasaron más de 150 años
antes de que la vacuna de la tuberculosis estuviera accesible para la mayoría.
¿Por qué?
En parte porque la sociedad pensaba que la tuberculosis
hacía que la gente fuera más sensible, creativa y empática
y que su origen era la complexión y no la biología.
Aún hoy se dicen cosas similares respecto a la depresión.
Y así como la invención de Jenner abrió las puertas
a todas las vacunas que se desarrollaron luego,
los fármacos que hemos descubierto abren las puertas a todo un nuevo campo:
la psicofarmacología preventiva.
Pero que esto suceda dentro de 15 o 150 años
depende no únicamente de la ciencia,
sino también de lo que la sociedad decida hacer al respecto.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)